gotta force it to come out what do you
you're a genius I know like what'd I say
Hello friends my name is Naz Perez and
you're watching the big ticket interview
for Blue Beetle and I am so excited to
talk to all of you here today because
I've been doing these interviews for
over a year now and this is the first
time I've sat down with a predominantly
latinx cast let's go let's go this is
such a big deal and I was thinking about
what I was prepping for this the first
Latino superhero I ever saw on screen I
don't know if you guys ever saw this TV
uh show in Mexico it was a comedy it was
called El Chapo of course we make a
reference to it in the movie oh my God
no way because he was inspired by a bug
too and he was just so uh legendary so
that's what I was thinking about as I
was prepping for this because that was
such a long time ago and now here we are
celebrating DC's first Latino live
action superhero Blue Beetle on the big
screen
yes wow this is gonna be loud
so the first thing that I thought was
really cool about Blue Beetle story is
that like other DC Superheroes like how
Superman has metropolis and Batman has
Gotham Jaime has Palmyra City so I
wanted you I wanted to first ask you
what is that City like and how is it
different than like a Gotham or
metropolis and this question is for all
of you guys well I'd say you know first
off with Palmera City it's a it's a city
made specifically kind of like for our
movie and for this storyline that we're
making with Blue Beetle and originally
the character takes place in El Paso
Texas and we decided to make it to
Palmera kind of what you were saying
Blue Beetle deserves his own city right
Batman has Gotham Superman has
metropolis and we wanted to to have a
world that felt like it was reminiscent
of the culture that Jaime grew up in
right it has the the the sound of a
place like like Rio or or the smell of
Boyle Heights or the people of an El
Paso but it's a metropolis of Latinos
and I think it it helped bring the story
from like an American story to a
worldwide kind of picture I love it I
can't wait to see it and I think the
kitchen was not big kitchen but there's
a lot that happens inside the house it
wasn't a big house but it is as as
authentic as any friend of mine I used
to go pick up for school and his grandma
was living with them and all the Trap is
all the chairs all the key chains all
the stuff that was in the wide open is
just amazing I mean the mullet or rat's
tail what what is that a mullet or a
rat's tail that you're wearing well you
know a lot of people would say rat's
tail but I say
it's so good I love that you brought up
the house George I can't wait to see
more of it because my favorite scene in
the trailer is when the Scarab
bonds with Jaime in the house and of
course for people watching who don't
know what the Scarab is it's this
ancient alien Relic chooses Jaime as its
host gives him these incredible Powers
this beautiful suit but for those of you
that were in that scene can you just
give me a scene breakdown of that
because it looked like so much fun
shooting it that was a really fun scene
to shoot I think that was one of my
favorite scenes to shoot it's like you
guys like days oh yeah it took us a few
days to do it and it's mainly because
there's it's so loud there's so much
screaming but what a what a fun scene to
get to just
that's that's kind of why you get
impacted you have to do the crazy Larger
than Life moments I think that was one
of the first things we shot together as
a family wasn't it it was the
transformation scene which I I think I
that's another reason I loved it so much
is because that whole scene we were also
finding the family within it through all
our reactions and I mean ankia are
amazing phenomenal director
um let us like run wild he was just like
go and we did and it was so much fun and
watching it you can see all that fun and
that chaos the absolute chaos that would
ensue in a Latino household if a bug a
metal alien bug was attaching itself in
the middle of your living room as soon
as he gets it in his hand he's not even
looking at it and it lights up and he
goes I think it likes me nothing is ever
the same after that yeah
and he doesn't like him by the way
for me it was it was the moment where
you're like get it off my face and you
see the moleta just go back and forth
yeah and then he had that guy on a on a
compression like wires like a piston
yeah that was crazy yeah watching that
stunt it was just shh it was really
George
I love that you said it doesn't like him
because the Scara very much has a mind
of its own and I know the incredible
director Angel Manuel Soto looked to a
lot of things for inspiration the new 52
run Infinite Crisis Injustice 2 video
game what type of personality does the
Scarab have and how does Jaime interact
with it it definitely like you said it
has a mind of its own but it also has an
objective like the the Scarab on each
planet has an objective and it you know
as nefarious as it may be the one on
earth or on at least time as Earth
doesn't follow its orders and and you
see it's at the beginning it's kind of
resistant to how righteous or or aloof
Jaime might be it's like ready to
destroy the world but uh that's kind of
the it's that's the great thing about
our story is that you know by the end of
the movie
both Kaji and Jaime are kind of in
different and he really can't see it so
there's a scene where he's putting on
his shirt and it's it's in the back it
turns around he goes and I'm like I'm
like hey there's something on and he's
like just like I don't need to hear this
and I'm like
coming out of the middle
yeah screaming is always fun we did a
lot of scraping screaming is so fun it's
so cathartic I can't wait to find out
more about the Scarab because to me the
coolest part about the Scarab is that
um it provides Blue Beetle with tools
and weapons based on what he imagines
and I was like thank God my Latina mom
didn't have one growing up because she
would be like wooden spoon wooden spoon
um but the sword
but the sword in the trailer it looks
like the Buster sword from like Final
Fantasy VII tell me how that was made
and what what was it like shooting with
that so you know the Ted cord gadgets
right as as Bruno and I'm sure can speak
to from the the Jenny chord side are are
inspired by Ted cord's designs and then
Jaime's Blue Beetle designs are inspired
by like what a 22 year old kid would
have liked like Angel is super into
anime I'm super into anime we love video
games we love Comics so it was really an
opportunity for us to both pay homage to
the things that as you know young kids
we liked you know Akita is a huge
inspiration for Angel wow that's really
cool and and getting to explore also the
alien part of it as well yeah and the
you know finding all of it but the Ted
core gadgets are much more eclectic than
yeah he was never able to use the power
so he has some some gizmos so we'll get
some pop culture references in there I
mean hundred percent right I still can't
believe at Chapel in Colorado today I'm
like oh my God that's amazing but also
the first real test of that is when you
see the big belly Burger you know so
people that know movies know the homage
of that you know so you see watch people
watch the trailer and people that really
are into that say oh look at the big
belly Burger I mean like it's a big
thing yeah I love how Milagros like you
haven't opened it yet like it's so
that's like common sense
of a burger I know we'd be like she's
not here like damn she got you whipped
like you listening to her immediately
like yes ma'am even talking to you guys
now it truly feels like you're such a
family and aside from like the weapons
and stuff we're gonna get to see it
feels like Jaime's real strength comes
from his family so let's talk about the
family George you play Rudy his uncle I
feel like the internet's always talking
about daddies and mothers but let's talk
about Uncle and Theo energy because Rudy
just seems hilarious his Batman is a
fascist line got so many reactions on
like do you have a favorite reaction
that you've seen to that you know Batman
is a fashion is a pretty good one
because they go George Lopez called
Batman a Fashions I'm like hey no no no
Uncle Rudy called Batman a fascist I
like Batman but you know it just when
the trailer came out it just it just
trended everywhere and it was I think it
was a great way to kind of plan our flag
that this movie's gonna be a little bit
different did you see a favorite
reaction online I mean on YouTube
there's just things that make people
just scream out loud yeah we all know
our favorite reaction but I mean Rudy I
mean the whole idea of having to hide
that rat's tail for you know six months
or three months that I was traveling
around it wouldn't let nobody you know
see it and then I was in New York at the
airport and I had it down and I saw that
guy Jerry Lorenzo from fear of God he's
like oh man I love your hair like that
bro you don't keep it like that I said
lost for things no no keep it bad she
looks nice wait so was it your hair or
they they put it in they put it in okay
but you kept it for months I kept you
know that's so cool
it looks so good on you did you as Rudy
get to say anything in Spanish or
Spanglish in the film that you were like
whoa I can't believe this is going to be
said on a superhero film oh
some this way and I thought I thought I
don't think in the DC or Marvel Universe
anybody ever said God is so this way
you're talking to a superhero so yeah
yeah but there's a lot more there's a
lot of stuff in there that yeah that we
have to look forward to there's some
stuff that's subtitled there's some
stuff that's not and then there's some
stuff that is hidden a little by sound
that's so cool I can't wait to see that
on screen um belisa you play Milagro
Jaime's sister what is their brother
sister relationship like and why is she
so important to Blue Beetle
um I think Milagro and Jaime definitely
grew up like very close and I think
Milagro as much as she's like Ugh like
I'm better like she's always looked up
to Jaime but like along with the rest of
the family I think it's important
because you know not only do we ground
Jaime throughout the film like when he's
struggling with becoming this massive
like superhero but we also lift him back
up by the end like it truly is a family
effort in this entire movie and
um
she's pretty cool yeah she's pretty cool
strong she seems pretty dope I'm excited
for that she had some of it from her
brother like I won't lie you know
I love you guys really feel like a real
family Bruna let's talk about uh Jenny
corn yeah
um I don't know if everyone watching
knows this but Jaime Reyes is actually
the third iteration of Blue Beetle after
Dan Garrett and Ted cord uh so I wanted
to know what is your character's
relation to Ted court and how do people
view Ted in this the world in this film
so Jenny's Ted's daughter which is
really exciting dead before disappearing
he was in charge of chord Industries and
now Janie's trying her best to keep her
dad's Legacy he is really important for
the movie though because we use all of
his gadgets it's the really the first
man cave I believe yeah
cuts of throwback so it's the first he's
got some Oreo cookies in there pallets
of Oreo cookies yeah the tools the bug
ship so thank you Dad because if it
wasn't for him working on restoring his
car yeah we wouldn't be yeah we still be
in the edge keys if it wasn't for Ted
yeah thanks I'm always curious is there
like a romantic connection between Jaime
and Jenny that we can look forward to
seeing in the movie or
how was she received when she walks into
the to the Reyes house
not really not fans us yeah especially
no oh really yeah Jaime is the the only
one that yeah likes she has two eyes and
eyelashes so I'm like she's
you're like that's all I need that's all
I need
um at first I don't think um Jenny's
looking for any romance she has a lot to
take her in his life already at first
time is the same way by the way oh yeah
but she's the one that
um gives him the the Scarab Scarab yeah
right so I'm sorry and you're welcome
the two great lines and also um I know
that Jenny's aunt is played by Susan
Sarandon
which is so cool I know so I wanted to
ask you what can you tell us about Susan
Sarandon Harvey Gan who I love and Raul
Max trujillo's villains in this movie
because what a trifecta man yeah yeah on
you know on the Reyes side you have kind
of the some of the people sitting here
and then on the other side of that the
the court side you have Susan Sarandon
who is kills it you know I it was quite
surreal to get to
be present with her and and to you know
act alongside of her and she's she was
so generous and really came through and
is really masterful and and really scary
as well she brings the Heat and I think
it's going to be really fun to see how
the the three like you were mentioning
Harvey or or Dr Sanchez carapax uh and
Susan's character all stand up against
these guys but they're you we're
formidable opponents as well like we're
yeah we're not gonna yeah you are you
guys have a bug ship which can we talk
about the buck ship The Buckshot the bug
shot wait what those pillows yeah wait
tell me more
it's it's
got some quirks too I'm thinking my
family's saying
but you know leave it to you know an
uncle to get something started that
hasn't been started in 30 days I finally
got that thing actually yeah yeah they
did a great job his secret Rudy way that
was really nice to to to film we had a
lot of fun in the book ship yeah the bug
ship I mean the set design for this
entire film is just phenomenal bug
bug layer like everything every bug
everything bugs every single bug in the
film down to the ant beautiful so we're
going to see more how many bugs are we
gonna see at least four there's at least
four bags at least four yeah at least he
already knows four bucks you've been
counting how did you feel about beetles
before taking on this role that's a good
one that's a good question I don't know
how often I'm coming into contact with
beetles yeah have you ever seen a beetle
yeah of course yeah yeah definitely seen
a beetle
the green ones yeah don't you catch them
yes they were like a kite yes the
Spanish Beetle yeah it's like a little
kid it's about to get canceled you're
about to get canceled
beetles
well I hope we get to see more of the
bug ship not just in this movie
um but like in future films too and Show
Low I wanted to ask you have you had any
conversations with James Gunn about the
future of Blue Beetle because he has a
connection to Peacemaker in the comics I
wanted to know are would you want to
appear in Peacemaker season two or the
one in the World Series yeah I've we all
want to
have had the pleasure of getting to
speak with Mr James Gunn and the whole
DC fan
um and you know at the end of the day I
think you know first we have to cross
this first Hill right and introduce
Jaime to the world but I think uh it's
up to the audience to to watch the movie
it's it's up to you know everyone to
show up for the movie and and it's so
wonderful that we get to make movies
like this uh and if it does well we'll
get to open more doors for more blue
beetles and not even just for the people
up here but there's
we've got a whole thing set up so so
many Beetles from so many Comics to
choose from and really just a whole
world where we're super appreciative
that that DC's you know took the first
swing at the the live-action Latino
superhero movie so we're ready to do it
again if the if the crowd wants it yeah
I know that people are super
appreciative that you are in the star
lead role when you were diving into
Jaime Reyes what about his story for you
made you go I can't wait for people to
see to find out this about him on screen
because we we see we meet so many
superheroes these days was there like
one thing that you specifically
connected to and related to now I
realize growing up as a Latino except
when I was growing up I didn't think
that way I was just like oh this is how
I grew up I I always have been super
close to my family and it's just been
how it's been like that my whole life
and it's been inherent it's I've never
known any difference and getting to be a
part of a movie where that is the same
case but just naturally just you know
without having to shove it in your face
or be like this is how the Latino life
is like it's just it's it's how all of
us have kind of grown up and that's why
it feels so natural that's that's one of
the main things I was excited about
getting to do this is portray this
family who even through strife and
struggle is like strong and like is
ready to to push on forward and and
getting and then the other part that
really made me excited is that he's he's
brown and and I thinking of Angel and I
had a lot of conversations about like
this is for us as kids you know we
didn't there weren't a ton of examples
uh at least on the big screen so that's
where and how much we all love
superheroes it's like I know right
thanks I love that it was all because of
Nacho Libra Jack Black you yes
um I love that you brought up family
though because the first time I ever saw
my family reflected on screen was thanks
to you George watching The George Lopez
Show and I think I speak for a lot of
people in my generation when first and
foremost I want to say thank you because
that was the first time we really felt
embraced by all types of different
audiences and there's a reason why you
are one of the 25 most influential
Hispanics in America according to Time
Magazine when you were on set for this
film George what were your Reflections
on the trail that you've blazed for so
many of us um well you know I think my
that first show was really kind of about
not really having a family and then
growing up and having a family so you
know
um having kids in that show was great
but also you know I don't really have a
lot of family that I speak to so uh to
get to be around them very emotional for
me because you know we really did feel
like a family really fast and did stuff
together so like I never let them know
that but it's uh it it means a lot to me
to be able to be embraced by by them
especially because I always felt like a
little bit of an outsider but you know
this this does put you in another place
so I appreciate that yeah and I know
what the show meant and it still means
to people so it means that to me too
it's such a beautiful sentiment was
there also a moment on set where you
were just like wow we've come so far or
we haven't come far I mean you know it's
just and I mean they're just amazing
actors so anytime that we all got
together and you look at them and you
see like these amazing actors with this
that it does down on you that's
something very special well thank you so
much for everything you've done for us
thank you all so much for your time and
for putting your love and art into this
film and thank you guys so much for
watching my name is Naz Perez tickets to
Blue Beetle are on sale right now on
fandango.com